we know how to take derivatives of
functions if I apply the derivative
operator to x squared I get 2x now if I
also apply the derivative operator to x
squared plus 1 I also get 2x if I apply
the derivative operator to x squared
plus PI I also get 2x the derivative of
x squared is 2x derivative with respect
to X of Pi of a constant is just 0
the derivative with respect to X of 1 is
just a constant it's just 0 so once
again this is just going to be equal to
2x in general the derivative with
respect to X of x squared plus any
constant any constant is going to be
equal to 2x the derivative of x squared
with respect to X is 2x derivative of a
constant with respect to X a constant
does not change with respect to X so
it's just equal to 0 so you have you
take the derivative you apply the
derivative operator to any of these
expressions and you get 2x now let's go
the other way around let's think about
the antiderivative anti derivative and
one way to think about it is the it's
the we're doing the opposite of the
derivative operator the derivative
operator you get an expression and you
find its derivative now what we want to
do is given some expression we want to
find what it could be the derivative of
what it could be the derivative of so if
someone were to tell you or give you 2x
if someone were to say 2x or let me find
it write this so if someone were to ask
you what is what is 2x the derivative
derivative of they're essentially asking
you for the anti derivative and so you
could say well 2x is the derivative of x
squared you could say 2x is the
derivative of x squared but you could
also say 2x is the derivative of x
squared plus 1
you could also say that 2x is the
derivative of x squared plus pi I think
you get the general idea so if you
wanted to write it in the most general
sense you would write that 2x is the
derivative
of x squared plus some constant so this
is what you would consider the
antiderivative of 2x now that's all nice
but this is kind of clumsy to have to
write a sentence like this so we let's
come up with some notation for the
antiderivative and the convention here
is to use kind of a strange-looking
notation is to use a a big elongated s
looking thing like that and the DX
around the function that you're trying
to take the antiderivative of so in this
case it would look something like this
this is just saying this is equal to the
antiderivative of 2x and the
antiderivative of 2x we have already
seen is x squared is x squared plus C
now you might be saying why do we use
this type of crazy notation it'll become
more obvious when we study the definite
integral and areas under curves and
taking sums of rectangles and in order
to approximate the area of the curve
here it really should just be viewed as
a notation for antiderivative and this
notation right over here this whole
expression is called the indefinite
integral the in definite in definite in
definite integral of 2x which is another
way of just saying the antiderivative of
2x